ah
[Música]
[Aplausos]
seguramente habrán escuchado hablar
sobre igualdad de género que implica
precisamente que tengamos todas las
mismas oportunidades también estoy casi
segura que habrán escuchado hablar sobre
la brecha de género que existe en todas
las áreas relacionadas con ciencia y
tecnología y siendo este un problema
global cómo podemos reducir esta brecha
de género esto es lo que les voy a
platicar el día de hoy entonces hablando
un poquito de lo que es este estén por
sus siglas en inglés son todas aquellas
áreas del conocimiento relacionadas con
ciencia tecnología ingeniería y
matemáticas les cuento que en lo
personal a la edad de 7 años admito que
me gustaba mucho jugar con muñecas tanto
que pues con mi hermana llegamos a jugar
y inventar historias con nuestras
muñecas sin embargo que creen también me
gustaba jugar con carritos me gustaba
jugar tanto que diseñaba a mí
pista mis propios caminos para que mis
carritos anduvieran ahí y ahí donde yo
es soy muy creyente en que la etapa de
la infancia se le debe fomentar la
creatividad la innovación dejar de echar
volar la imaginación en nuestros niños
no los regañan porque quieran ellos
destrozar sus juguetes a lo mejor ellos
quieren descubrir cómo funcionan esos
juguetes
en áfrica y siendo fui incursionando en
el arte mi madre me inspiró para dibujar
y pues que creen que dibujaba carritos
estos eran algunos de los carritos que
dibujaban según yo dije último modelo
este es el que tengo que dibujar pero al
ir madurando me fui dando cuenta que
aunque es mi pasión me llamaba mucho la
atención saber cómo funcionaba un auto
estas máquinas impresionantes para mí
decía bueno podré estudiar alguna
carrera cuando yo sea grande que me
permita entender cómo funcionan estas
máquinas pues yo no sabía realmente pero
sí decidí estudiar ingeniería una
ingeniería que me permitió ver más allá
que el diseñar un auto el entender cómo
funciona un auto me permitió saber cómo
va a ayudar a nuestra comunidad
entonces lo que provocó fue que me
encantará tanto la investigación que
pues me permití
junto con mi director de tesis
desarrollar un proyecto beneficio de la
comunidad en detección de fatiga mental
que les cuento que en mi universidad era
la única mujer en el salón y en mi
posgrado éramos sólo dos o tres mujeres
por cada laboratorio
y hablando un poco entonces del área de
investigación les comento que el sistema
nacional de investigadores reúne a los
mejores científicos del país y ellos
reportan en el 2017 que éramos apenas
36.6 por ciento son mujeres
investigadoras solamente 36.6 por ciento
también les comparto según la encuesta
nacional de ocupación y empleo en el
2017 que éramos en méxico alrededor de
un millón setecientos treinta y siete
mil profesionales que estábamos
dedicados completamente a la ingeniería
sin embargo el 19 por ciento solamente
son mujeres que está pasando y de menor
participación las áreas de menor
participación son las enfocadas más
específicamente en electrónica en
eléctrica en automotriz entonces qué es
lo que está sucediendo
un día llega a mi oficina porque soy
académica también llega mi colega la
doctora ingrid kuri a quien admiro
bastante catedrática de la escuela de
humanidades y sociales ella en su
estudio dice precisamente que las
mujeres nuestras jóvenes de bachillerato
presentaban un alto desempeño en físico
matemático pero no ingresaban a la
universidad en un área stem entonces por
qué es importante este tema porque de
lograr la equidad de género a nivel
global lo que va a suceder es que se
aumentaría el producto interno bruto
mundial éste incrementaría la riqueza
mundial
y en este caso se puede lograr en menos
de una década según un estudio del
mckinsey global institute en el 2017 que
podemos hacer prácticamente lo que
nosotros abrimos a la comunidad es
ofrecemos talleres de electrónica
ofrecemos talleres de diseño mecánico
para que nuestras niñas de primaria
secundaria y de jóvenes bachillerato
puedan lograr entender que la ingeniería
no es tan difícil en el sentido de que
no lo vean inalcanzable que sino que si
tú crees que no eres buena en
matemáticas no creas que porque tú no lo
eres así todos somos capaces de entender
la matemática tal vez la técnica de
estudio la tengas que cambiar o tal vez
tengas que inspirarte para lograr
entender esta área no significa no
significa que todas tengamos que
estudiar ingeniería esto significa que
las stem apoya a la comunidad
en el ámbito tecnológico pero tan
importante son como lo es un médico no
es un administrador todas las áreas son
importantes para nuestra comunidad sin
embargo en las stem apoyamos de manera
tecnológica a dar soluciones a beneficio
de nuestra comunidad les comparto que
también hemos ofrecido pláticas para
padres de familia en donde les
especificamos que inspiren a sus hijos
ya no tanto a las niñas a todos a sus
niños a sus niñas a que logren crear un
proyecto de vida que es ese proyecto de
vida un proyecto de vida implica que
ellos a temprana edad piensen que la
sociedad necesita de su apoyo ellos son
la generación del futuro entonces
necesitan ellos crear un proyecto de
vida que nos haga sentir que nos hagan
pensar en que ellos van a salvar el
planeta como tal vez no sepan que
estudiar todavía a muy temprana edad es
muy difícil escoger la carrera
profesional yo me di cuenta en la
preparatoria
pero eso es importante para ellos que
creen un proyecto de vida y que padres
de familia a ustedes los invito a que
salgan hoy e invitan a sus hijos a
pensar en el futuro gracias
[Música]
[Aplausos]